we're just one day from a deadline set
by North Korea to softened sanctions
against its nuclear program the country
warned of a quote Christmas gift for the
US if it doesn't happen and the North
claims at least one successful missile
related test this month
overnight Kim jong-un urged members of
his party to quote take positive and
offensive measures for fully ensuring
the sovereignty and security of the
country Barry Petersen is monitoring
this story in Seoul South Korea Barry
what was Kim jong-un essentially trying
to say there well I have to tell you
when the land known as the Hermit
Kingdom it's not always easy to know
what Kim jong-un is thinking we know
they're up to something
we just don't know what that something
is was center stage at the Workers Party
meeting a rare event in North Korea
called because Kim is thinking of taking
the country on a different course in
recent years he has been downplaying the
military in favor of boosting the
emerging middle class by getting more
consumer goods into the country but
after summits with President Trump did
not ease economic sanctions the war of
words escalated one North Korean
official calling president Trump a
heedless and erratic old man there is a
real worry that Kim will go back to the
days of nuclear brinkmanship and
long-range ballistic missile launches a
move already drawing fire from the
president's national security adviser
who said the US would take appropriate
military or economic action
South Koreans are so afraid that
President Trump may make a deal with Kim
to withdraw American troops that the US
ambassador was page one news today in
Seoul saying US troops are going to stay
David Larry Peterson in Seoul South
Korea Thank You Barry
you